do you know they had me swim with sharks
once automatically I'm nervous
and so before the shoot I took 100
milligram edible
and if I could
and I'm like okay I'm just to take the
edge off you know what I mean
so we got out there and they put me in
the I'd never been in a what they call
this wetsuit never been in one before
and um
I never snorkeled in my life
and so they got a snorkel wetsuit
and um I said I said the guy on camera
the guys like this so here's what's
gonna happen they tell me all this stuff
I go wait a second ago are you gonna
are you gonna teach me how to snorkel
and he goes what
I go I've never worn a wetsuit before
and I don't know how to snorkel he goes
can you cut
and they cut and he goes you've never
done this I go no he goes come get give
me the other waiver
I go what and he goes the other way but
he goes you have to sign the second
waiver I'm like what's the second waiver
and he was like the death one
yeah
yeah he called it death one right yeah
and he goes he goes you got to make sure
he was like because
he goes here's the deal he goes you've
never been a white suit before I go no
he goes you know we're putting a weight
on this I go what
because first of all he's telling
everybody
he's gonna jump in
he's gonna drop
the water's gonna go in the snorkel he's
going to panic he's gonna sink he's
gonna die
I go yeah but what if that doesn't
happen he goes okay if that doesn't
happen you're gonna jump in you've never
been in a wetsuit the weight is going to
pull you straight down you're gonna
Panic you're gonna die
laughs
I go what if that doesn't happen he goes
well that doesn't happen and somehow you
figure out how to float you've never
swung swam in a wetsuit or a snorkel
like oh no he goes the current's gonna
take you
you're gonna get tired you're gonna sink
you're gonna die
I go to him I go what what ends with me
not dying he was like you staying on the
boat
so I was like well we can't do that we
have to shoot this
and he was like okay because here was
the bit
we were getting in the water they were
throwing Chum in the water so snake so
sharks could come up and we could film
it
and so
he was like okay he'll go around there
we're gonna tie a rope around your waist
we're going to tie you to the boat
we're going to take the weight off you
because the wetsuit's buoyant
he goes here's a couple problems one
you're gonna look a lot like a seal
I said what he goes yeah it's even worse
because we're going to be throwing Chum
around you
for those who don't know what Chum is
Chum is the
sharks and he goes so here's the deal
if the shark comes up to you
and it bumps you
don't let it bump you again
I said why and he goes well they bump
you the first time it's like a test
to see what the deal is and if you let
it bump you again
you can go for a taste he said so when
it comes up just push its nose away I'm
like
I said its nose it's right near it's
mouth
and he goes yeah but just don't miss I'm
like what
I was like but my hand is moving so
slowly in the water what if it just
moves its head he was like that could
happen
and I was like well I hope the shark
doesn't like the taste of because
that's what I'll be doing
you can find me by the brown Cloud you
know what I'm saying
he kidding me so they tied me to
the boat by the way you know what my
producer said you looked like bait
so they tied me to the boat they threw
Chum around me and these sharks came
around yo I like to smoke weed bring it
I like to smoke weed
I like to smoke weed bring it
[Applause]
[Music]